There is a precise moment when you
realize that blood is sometimes poison.  Have you
ever wondered why, despite all
your superhuman efforts to keep
your family together, [music] certain relationships
seem destined to crumble in
your hands?
Maybe you prayed for peace, to
find an impossible compromise, to be
accepted by the one who was supposed to
love you unconditionally.
Yet, the more you tried, the more the distance
between you became unbridgeable,
leaving you exhausted and empty.
Today I want to tell you something that might
overturn everything you've been
taught since you were a child.
What if that painful separation
wasn't your failure, but a
divine response?
What if God or the higher intelligence
of the universe was literally
cutting off dead branches to prevent
the infection from reaching your deepest roots
?  In this video we explore
an uncomfortable and powerful truth.
I'll show you how
biblical wisdom combined with the insights of
modern psychology reveal that losing
a toxic family is often not a
punishment, but the greatest act of
protection you will ever receive
in your life.  Imagine your
existence as a precious garden
entrusted to you for your
sole custody.  For years you've watered
plants that, instead of blooming and providing
shade, have absorbed all the water and
then released thorns and toxins into the
soil.  The culture we live in,
especially the Italian one,
deeply rooted in the idea of
Christmas being all together regardless,
makes you believe that the family is an
untouchable institution, [music] a
sacred altar on which you have to sacrifice
your mental well-being in order to keep up
appearances.  But science tells us
something very different and the numbers give us pause for
thought.  Cornell University sociologist Carl Pilemer
conducted a
monumental 10-year study,
finding that a full 27 percent of
adults have permanently cut
ties with at least one member of their
family of origin.   We
're not talking about
teenage tantrums or passing [music] arguments
.
We are talking about adults who had to
amputate a limb to save the
rest of their body from gangrene.  When
a family member [music] manipulates you,
constantly belittles you, or uses
guilt as an invisible leash,
your nervous system is in a
constant state of alarm, producing cortisol
as if it were at war.
Emotional detachment, in these extreme cases,
[music] is not an act of
cruel selfishness, it is a
necessary survival protocol to avoid going
mad.  And here a shocking concept comes into play
, an
age-old truth that is rarely preached
from traditional pulpits.
Have you ever carefully read the Gospel
of Luke, chapter 14?
Jesus uses words that seem like stones
thrown at do-goodism.
If anyone comes to me and does not hate his father and
mother, wife and children,
brothers and sisters, yes, and his
own life also, he cannot be my
disciple.  Stop for a moment and breathe.
The God of absolute love who speaks of
hate seems an unacceptable paradox.
Biblical scholars
explain that in ancient Aramaic
this term does not indicate
malicious contempt or wickedness, but establishes
a precise scale of vital priorities.
it means loving [music] less, or
rather, it means that no
earthly bond, however biologically
close, must have the power to
distance you from your integrity, from
your inner light and from the path of
evolution that you are called to follow.
If a parent or sibling drags you
into the darkness of their narcissism,
the most profound and radical lesson is
that you must have the courage to let
go of the rope before you fall into the
abyss with them.  Think about the
story of Joseph and his brothers in the
book of Genesis.
It is perhaps the first great
psychological treatise in human history on
dysfunctional family dynamics.
His own brothers, blinded by a
fierce envy, throw him into an
empty cistern and sell him as a slave
to passing merchants.  [music] It is
the ultimate betrayal, the purest pain
, perpetrated by those who
share your same roof and your
same blood.  Yet, if you look at the
story from a higher angle, that
atrocious betrayal is precisely the
mechanism that allows Joseph to
arrive in Egypt, rise through
hardship, [music] become
governor, and ultimately save an entire
nation from famine.
If his brothers had loved him
normally, he would have remained
forever herding flocks in Canaan,
totally unaware of his true,
immense potential.  Sometimes God allows
those around you to turn their
[music] back on you in a cruel way, not
because they hate you or want to punish you, but
because the environment you find yourself in has
become too small, too narrow
for what you need to become.
Abandonment is not your grave, it becomes
your catapult to a greater destiny
.  Have you ever felt
consumed by guilt for
setting clear boundaries with a [music]
relative who was systematically hurting you
?
Let me know in the comments below because
I know exactly how heavy that weight is
on my chest, and talking about it together helps us
understand that we're not alone in this
silent trench.  Many of us
remain trapped for
decades in poisonous dynamics because
we confuse Christian forgiveness with
unlimited access
to our own vulnerability.
In the book of Proverbs there is a warning as
clear and sharp as a blade.
He who walks with the wise becomes wise, but a
companion of fools becomes
evil.  Note well, there is no asterisk
at the bottom of the page that says: "Unless the
fools have your last name."
The energy of the people you hang out with is
as contagious as a highly
transmissible virus.
If those who should be encouraging you spend their
time tearing down your self-esteem drop
by drop, reminding you of your
past failures as if they were trophies, or
secretly competing with you at every
opportunity, they
are slowly poisoning your soul.
To forgive means to free yourself
from corrosive resentment.   It does
n't mean at all to invite [music] the
person who just stabbed you to sit
back at your table with a
sharp knife in his hand.  Perhaps right now
you are dealing with the
cold void left by a
recent breakup.  Sunday lunches have
suddenly become quieter,
and there's an empty chair in the room that
makes a deafening noise in your head.
I want you to look at that void not as
an irreparable loss, but as a
space finally cleared of
rubble.  Experts in
toxic family dynamics teach us that the
main symptom of a
dysfunctional family [music] is the
absolute obligation of omertà-like silence.  Whoever tells
the truth, whoever exposes the problem, whoever
stops pretending that everything is fine,
immediately becomes the
scapegoat to be taken down.
If you've been isolated or if you've had to
run away to avoid going mad, it
means you're the strong link that
broke the spell of
generational lies.
You are the bearer of a truth that the
sick system could not tolerate
without collapsing.  The
temporary isolation you are experiencing is the
high but necessary price you pay to
regain your sanity and
dignity.  [music]
God or the universe or whatever higher wisdom
you believe in, very often uses
unbearable discomfort to forcefully move you
from places you shouldn't be in for
even a minute.
It's exactly like when you hold your hand
on a hot plate.
Excruciating pain is not your enemy.
It's the vital warning signal that
forces you to withdraw your hand before you
burn yourself completely to the bone.
If you are experiencing rejection, coldness,
or outright hostility from your family
of origin, please do not try to
force open a door that has been locked from
the other side.  Stop
knocking where they don't want you to enter.
Use this new immense freedom,
painful and frightening as it may seem at first, to build
your chosen family,
one made up of people who
consciously choose you for who you are
today, for the light you emanate [music] and
not for the submissive role you had to
play in yesterday's family play
.  Always remember and carry it with you
as a shield.  Your roots are not
just the biological ones you were
assigned at birth.  Your
deepest roots, the ones that will keep you
standing during life's storms,
are the ones you plant yourself in the
fertile soil of mutual respect,
loyalty, and authentic love.  If
these words have given you a
new perspective on a wound you've been
carrying around for too long, if they've
lit a spark of awareness,
sign up for a mental dose.
Here, we daily confront the
most uncomfortable and fascinating truths of
psychology and ancient wisdom to
give you the practical tools you need to
build a mind of steel and a life
finally free from
invisible chains.   I'll
wait for you in the next one